e aí
e a falta de ar
e ela ela não é
a escolha é nossa
a ver com consumo
[Música]
e aí
e vamos vou maquiar imagem fofa para
assistir pela mulher grávida
tradicionais com duas que está
acontecendo no mundo o que faz para mim
confortável para conferir
e a nossa vida com tudo que está
acontecendo estão lá em casa então pões
quando eu devo ficar quieta que pode
fazer sentido para mim a sugestão é que
você possa olhar nos olhos e me fala
para todo mundo econômico e ao nós vamos
trabalhar não vai dar
o relatório não vai te fala comigo e que
fala com rodrigo confiar nós pronto aí
alguma coisa é a minha vida que estava
e aí
a cada vez que antes
tô brincando mais seus passos instale o
que era simplesmente um
e aí
e aqui mais do que saudade da minha se
forem passar o fig
o que pode passar seu rosto porque eu
vou pagar vai na vó
e a filha dela pessoa sincera
e como assim
e mais é um público que vocês se
inscrever no mundo inteiro e
e quando éramos local mensagem sim a
vida tô saindo tipo lá provocar fala
mais não é
é um hotel simples vai saber quem é
e amigos não se ele é totalmente já já
tá então a
e aí
oi oi
é um papo o meio ambiente economia que
fala qual que é a opção
e ela tá internada
é que tá lá então você tá na
e aí
o bicho rafa acho que me fez livramento
é uma coisa que eu ficava suas famílias
que você construiu um rápida que tá
feita a vitória tá assim tá pensando no
que ele é que nossa tem proprietário
assim e você e o faço feliz se bloqueia
a pessoa não tomar minhas canções para
e nós temos mais um problema no pronto
pontuações só e até você que fala mais
ou menos instagram pastor falta de ações
estratégicas que ficam me ligar se for
comigo apoiar a posição do mundo não
mais amortecimento no então vocês também
a população ficar totalmente passada
porque mas mesmo que você não aumentar
uma propriedade e é isso gente tava se
tem que ter algum momento da nossa vida
ela tem
e o outro mas tempo
a sala ficava no lugar juízos e nós
reciclamos assim passou uma luzinha
trabalhando entendo trabalhamos e janta
final do livro estão metals
e aí
o que é que eu fiz o produto fica muito
elevado não sei lá na minha família
então não
g1
eu não consigo ficar com relações onde
eu possa começar a mesma coisa pessoal a
minha calça total com a humanizar os
desafios que elas têm que eu vezes o
motivo estão falando então caindo a
gente tem que ficar o menor lutando
oi oi
e aí
e no telefone não tem casa e tem
problema não vai ficar as pessoas que lá
moram uma coragem
ir para a escola mas não responde folha
de morar na amazônia
em apodi o vai mandar uma floresta mais
fazer segundo que largou encontrar os
correntinhas e lá porque eu queria
conectar com a natureza olha o resultado
do meu em todos eu não tinha muito posso
conectar assim tecnologia do mundo
inteiro faz outros não sei né porque
tava com nossas ele já ministrou eu falo
e ajustar e conseguir apresenta triste
ver no local fui nós nos conectamos após
a alma melancia depois eu vim com uma
grande oportunidade vovós ajudar namorar
com você sabe demorar errado tudo ficam
indo lá no floresta amazônica onde
faltavam demorar uma hora gostoso mais
sobre o nosso teclados que me lembra
muito a calça participação no casa tanto
flávio kotaka
e se fosse é uma
a foto do que
e aí
eu estava lá em casa
e eu tenho que falar com você ainda mais
mapa falar com as normas recursos mas
não precisa ficar não e você acha que eu
comi trágica como a gente a gente assim
se eu quiser colocar que quando você vai
fazer você olha todas aquele material
é muito sono que material está uma
rapidinha aqui nós temos um
e aí
é mas é uma realidade tem que fazer
então a
e aí
esse é o frente do centro da capa
é para ir todo lado e fazendo dele assim
aí já sai escrito e probabilidades e
você provavelmente é um
e aí
bom então isso
e depois vai ser fácil de alguma quando
eu vou ficar muito muito
e aí
eu vou
a mensagem aqui ó que bom sozinho de
sofrer muito pra vocês mas não
e aí
o cabo que me importa o teu namorado só
e fraco e para você tava só olhando foi
aprender a colocar para sentar no dias
e aí
g1
o novato um pouco de tudo isso seja
negado tudo bem por favor nós temos
muitas coisas assim
e aí
o quê
se tiver alguma coisa por quê
e aí
a superfície todas as
e como baixar tá bom processo produto e
o trabalho e ovário
e quando eu vou usar
e aí
o que faz isso aqui não vai conseguir e
vai estar em algum lugar e depois vai
fazer cachos
ou então comprar um negócio na laboração
usam
o meu cavalo nosso vivo global então
então vai ser vivo se você pessoalmente
sustentável
e eu faço um papo um país que está vendo
responsabilizados faço com fernando
responsabilidade falei empresa
responsabilidade para a textura
responsabilidade para mim mostrar para
você então
o que falta filme falei
a cada dia
é uma coisa saiu dizendo
o mercado causa que o mundo gira online
isso folheto assim como opção
eu posso usar fantasia que ficar aqui
aqui vamos comprar então contém os
pequenos negócios que eu estou avisando
o nosso vocês assim os nossos pais estão
todos os dois
o seu vamos as pessoas que ele precisa
da sua família ou você precisa eles não
não sei o tempo da capacidade eu já
quantidade de vezes pai
bom então aqui é muito logo ao meio
economia local pintado e ainda mais nós
podemos fechar os nossos mas ela falta
portugal a todas as ele fez qualquer
parte que você goza fazendo que se a
nossa essência de cada ele mas escolha
as nossas escolhas nos leva a economia a
economia é
é conectado obrigado a economia global
obrigada a todas todos os fácil globo
a humanidade escolha uma
é assim que fala
e aí
e sempre conectar a volta tá
o que significa alegada pode ficar
oi gente vai passar mas você pode ficar
falando no carro olhando para você
e aí você pode mim por favor
e aí